[Música]
Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos paraa nossa live nível dois,
estudos avançados. É um grande prazer
tê-los conosco. Seja bem-vindo. Tchau.
Cada vez mais esses nomes de membros
diferentes, né? Seja bem-vindo, Adriana
Quintas. Seja bem-vindo todos que estão
acompanhando ao vivo ou estão vendo a
gravação. Lembrando, é uma coisa meio
óbvia, mas tem que falar toda vez. Todas
as lives ficam gravadas, todas, tá? E
quem tem acesso ao nível um consegue ver
as lives do nível um. Quem tem acesso a
nível dois consegue ver todas as lives
do grupo fechado. Aí vamos começar aqui.
Depois eu vou entendo vocês à medida que
vocês vão entrando.
Bem, hoje eu vou contar uma história que
talvez mude completamente a forma como
você enxerga a sua energia, a sua saúde
e até mesmo o câncer, porque tem algo
acontecendo dentro de cada célula do
nosso corpo.
Nesse exato momento, algo minúsculo, mas
incrivelmente poderoso, que decide se eu
ou você vamos acordar dispostos ou se
vamos passar o dia inteiro nos
arrastando.
Então, esse fato decide se seu cérebro
vai funcionar 1000 ou se você vai ter
aquela sensação de nevo, de neblina, de
fogue mental. E pasm pode até decidir se
você vai desenvolver um tumor ou não. Eu
acho que vocês podem até ter adivinhado
do que eu tô falando. Eu tô falando das
mitocôndrias.
Boa noite, Cristina Carol. Seja muito
bem-vinda à nossa live.
E o mais assustador nisso tudo que eu tô
contando para vocês, a maioria das
pessoas anda por aí com essas usinas de
energia trabalhando a meio vapor, sem
fazer a menor ideia que está acontecendo
isso e acha que tá deprimido e acha que
tá com algum problema que não é
relacionado à mitocôndria. Então fica
comigo porque nos próximos minutos eu
vou te mostrar exames que existem aqui
no Brasil e alguns que não existem, né,
disponíveis para ver como é que estão as
mitocôndrias. Então vão revelar
exatamente como é que está o motor
energético do seu corpo a nível celular.
E também isso é muito importante. Isso
não é papo de energia mística, apesar
que eu acredito na energia mística. Isso
é ciência pura de ponta publicada nos
últimos 2 anos. Boa noite, Dra. Ana
Paula. Seja muito bem-vinda.
Boa noite a todos aqui. Parabéns para
quem decidiu aprender mais sobre sua
saúde. Obrigado pelo comentário.
Muito bem,
vamos continuar aqui. Então, vamos
começar pelo básico, né? De um jeito que
faça sentido para vocês que estão
escutando. As mitocôndrias são
organelas, ou seja, pequenos órgãos que
vivem dentro das células. Algumas
células têm dezenas, outras centenas e
outras milhares de mitocôndrias, tá?
Pensa nelas como pequenas baterias, ou
melhor, como usinas termoelétricas
altamente sofisticadas, microscópicas,
que produzem ATP, que é a nossa moeda
energética, através de uma via chamado
fosforilação oxidativa. Então, cada vez
que você pisca, pensa, respira ou o
coração bate, você tá gastando energia o
tempo todo. Tá gastando ATP. E sabe
quantas mitocôndas você tem em cada
célula? Isso varia muito. Barbaridade,
eu comentei, mas vamos esmiçar.
Uma célula hepática pode ter mais de
2.000 mitocôndrias.
E aqui, isso aqui até eu fiquei muito
surpreso com isso. Eu não tinha ideia.
Eu achei até que essa informação tava
errada, mas neurônios podem ter até 2
milhões de mitocôndrias, né? Porque o
neurônio pode ser muito longo, né? Deve
ser por isso já. parou para pensar por
que o cérebro e o coração são os
primeiros a sofrer quando a produção de
energia cai, porque esses são os dois
órgãos que as células gastam mais
energia e tem mais mitocôndrias por
célula, né? São tecidos extremamente
dependentes de metabolismo oxidativo. O
que que significa oxidativo? Que usa
oxigênio, tá? Toda vez que eu vê a
palavra oxidação, oxidativo tá se
relacionando ao oxigênio. Então, nem
sempre o estresse oxidativo é ruim, tá?
Nossas células imunes usam o estresse
oxidativo para defesa. E, por exemplo,
se você tem um câncer, tá falando
tratamento, é interessante fazer
terapias oxidativas para ajudar a matar
células tumorais. Agora vem a parte que
tá deixando a comunidade científica
mundial de cabelo em pé. Estudos
publicados em 2024, nesse ano em
periódicos como Cell Metabolism, o
Nature Reviews, o Signal Transduction e
o Targeted Therapy e Goscience confirmam
com cada vez mais solidez que disfunção
mitocondrial não é só sobre cansaço, é
sobre praticamente todas as doenças
crônicas que você já tenha ouvido falar:
Alzheimer, Parkson, diabetes tipo 2,
cardiovasculares,
fadiga crônica, fibromialgia, covid
longa, doenças músculoesqueléticas
crônicas e também o câncer.
E aqui entra um conceito absolutamente
fundamental que pouca gente fala ou
discute com pacientes, no caso dos
médicos. A inflamação crônica de origem
mitocondrial é algo bem comum e pouco
discutido. Então, deixa eu explicar para
vocês como isso funciona, porque quando
você entende esse mecanismo, muita coisa
começa a fazer sentido. Então, quando as
mitocôndrias estão disfuncionais, ou
seja, não estão funcionando bem, elas
começam a liberar moléculas que
funcionam como se fossem sinais de
perigo para o sistema imune. Então, ela
fica perigo, perigo. Não sei se o
pessoal daqui das antigas vai lembrar
daquele seriado e do tinigo,
Will Robinson, perigo, Will Robinson. E
recentemente até acho que a Netflix
soltou um seriado, eh, uma renovação
desse perigos perdidos no espaço, né?
Então, só uma pequena aqui eh mudança de
assunto aqui. Então, a quando as
mitocôndas estão disfuncionais, elas
começam a liberar essas moléculas que
vão dar o sinal de perigo Will Robson,
perigo Will Robson para o sistema imune.
Então, estudos de 2024 e 25 mostram que
mitocôndrias danificadas liberam
fragmentos de DNA mitocondrial, tá?
Então, a mitocôndria é danificada, ela
estraga, libera DNA mitocondrial, também
vai liberar espécies reativas de
oxigênio, outras substâncias como
cardiolipina, o próprio ATP, né, que é a
moeda energética, sucinato e fumarato,
que são substâncias aí do ciclo de
crebes e peptídeos enformilados, tá? Eu
sei que tá difícil essas palavras, mas
vocês estão em grupos avançados, né? Meu
papel aqui pegar coisas difíceis e
tentar simplificar. Então, libera essa
série de substâncias pro citoplasma, né?
Vocês lembram que o citoplasma é aquela
parte interna da célula onde estão as
organelas e libera até pra circulação
sistêmica. E aqui vem o pulo do gato. O
DNA mitocondrial não é mitilado nos
domínios CPG, que é o que acontece, por
exemplo, com o DNA das bactérias. O que
que significa isso? Essa essa esse termo
que parece tô falando grego aqui. As
mitocôndrias elas são descendentes
evolutivas de bactérias antigas,
bactérias aeróbicas que foram
incorporados à células eucariotas, que
são as células que t núcleo verdadeiro.
Isso aconteceu há bilhões de anos atrás.
Então, o DNA mitocondrial parece muito
com de uma bactéria das antigas, uma
bactéria arqueia, por exemplo, e por
isso ela não tem essa metilação nos
nomínios CPG, tá? Lembra só isso por
enquanto. Já vou explicar qual que é a
importância disso aí. Então, quando
fragmentos de DNA mitocondrial cai no
citoplasma, o sistema imune reconhece
isso como se fosse uma invasão
bacteriana, tá? Então ele vai ativar
receptores tol, são receptores de
defesa, tolike 9, uma via chamado
cegasting
e principalmente o inflamaçoma NLRP3.
Durante o covid se falou muito sobre
inflamaçoma, pelo menos nos meios de
medicina, né, que foi muito estudado
isso durante o COVID. Então, o
inflamaçoma, que que ele é? O inflamçoma
é um complexo proteico dentro da célula
citoplasmático, que quando ele é
ativado, ele leva à maturação de
citocinas pró-inflamatórias, que é o
caso de teleocina um beta e teleocina
18,
e induz a piropitose, tá? Piropitose,
que que é isso? um tipo de morte celular
programada que é de origem inflamatória
e ela é mediada por um marcador aí
chamado gasderminde. Desculpa tá falando
essas palavras difíceis, mas se vocês
não entenderem alguma coisa, a gente
explica. E aqui tá o problema da
situação, tá? Essa ativação do
inflamaçoma mediada por disfunção
mitocondrial cria um ciclo vicioso.
Então, de novo, morre lá a mitocôndria.
Ela libera o DNA mitocondrial que não
tem aquela metilação, cai na circulação
sanguínea cá no citoplasma,
induz a liberação de marcadores
inflamatórios e induz também a ativação
do sistema imune. É basicamente isso,
tá? Então, a inflamação que acontece
danifica mais mitocôndrias, mais
mitocôndrias são danificadas que vão
liberar mais marcadores, inclusive os
dumps, né, que é o damage associated
molecular pattern, é o padrão molecular
associado ao dano, tá? Isso vai ativar
mais inflamação. Então, é um loop, é um
loop, tá? morre a mitocôndria. A
mitocôndria libera resto que vai induzir
inflamação, a inflamação mata
mitocôndria e fica esse loop aí. Então,
pesquisas publicadas ano passado
demonstram que essa comunicação
bidirecional entre mitocôndrias
disfuncionais e o sistema imune está no
centro da patogênese, ou seja, da
geração das doenças neurodegenerativas,
cardiovasculares, músculoesqueléticas e
metabólicas.
E no caso do Alzheimer, especificamente,
a disfunção mitocondrial nos neurônios e
na micrógra, que são células de defesa
lá dos neurônios, que deveriam proteger
os neurônios, mas às vezes ao invés de
proteger, ataca os neurônios. Então essa
disfunção mitocondrial leva à liberação
de DNA mitocondrial que ativa o
inflamaçoma NLRP3,
aumenta heterleucina um beta e essa
heterleucina 1 beta aumentada vai ser
encontrada em vários líquidos corporais,
por exemplo, no sangue, no líqu, né, que
é o líquido céfaloquidiano e no tecido
cerebral de pessoas com Heimer. Então é
comprovado que aumenta esse marcador
inflamatório em vários locais de quem
tem Alzheimer. Isso vai potencializar a
produção neuronal da betamloide e
induzir hiperfosforilação
da proteína tal, ou seja, vai promover
justamente a formação daqueles
marcadores de proteínas disfuncionais do
Alzheimer. de novo, aumenta betamiloide
e induz a formação da proteína tal, que
a gente chama de hiperfosforilação.
Ou seja, a inflamação mitocondrial
não é consequência da doença, ela é
parte do mecanismo causador da doença,
né? Aquela história do ovo e da galinha.
Então, a inflamação mitocondrial é causa
e não é consequência.
Em doenças cardiovasculares, estudos
desse ano também mostraram que o DNA
mitocondrial circulante, aquele DNA que
foi liberado pela lesão da mitocôndria,
vai aumentar gradualmente com a idade
após a quinta década de vida, né, após
os 50 anos. E a abundância desse DNA
mitocondrial livre está relacionado
associado a envelhecimento acelerado e
maior risco cardiovascular. E olha que
interessante, quando você trata a
disfunção mitocondrial, você vai na
origem do problema. Independentemente da
doença específica, você vai ter o quê?
Uma melhora generalizada. Por quê?
Porque você está cortando o mal pela
raiz. Mecanismo inflamatório. OK?
Estudos mostram que intervenções que
melhoram a função mitocondrial. é o caso
do exercício físico de alta intensidade,
o jejum intermitente, a dieta cetogênica
aquetoflex, que eu promovo, a
suplementação com com enzima Q10, PQQ,
que são assuntos de vídeos recentes do
canal, também precursores do Nad mais,
pode ser a nicotinamida mononucleotídio
ou a nicotinamida ribosídio, né?
Compostos que estimulam biogênese
mitocondrial através da ativação do quê?
do PGC1 alfa, tá? Então isso vai reduzir
marcadores inflamatórios sistêmicos e
melhorar várias condições de saúde
simultaneamente. Então isso explica
porque pacientes que implementam
protocolo de utilização mitocondrial
frequentemente relatam melhora não só no
sintoma principal, mas em várias áreas,
mais energia, melhor cognição, redução
de dor crônica, melhor humor, melhor
controle do açúcar. melhor função
cardiovascular. Então você não tá
tratando doenças isoladas, você tá
tratando o denominador comum, que é a
disfunção mitocondrial, que gerou a
inflamação crônica sistêmica.
Temos mais comentários aqui. Vocês estão
me ouvindo bem, né, pessoal? Por favor,
Dra. Ana Paula, me dê um feedback. Você
tá ouvindo? Cristina Carol também, por
favor. Eu acho que a Estela Mares vai
entrar mais tarde também. Bom, vamos
continuar.
Vamos ao que interessa na prática
clínica.
Como é que nós fazemos para descobrir se
as suas mitocôndrias estão disfuncionais
e se essa inflamação mitocondrial está
presente ou não? Obrigado, Trana Paula.
Porque não adianta nada eu ficar aqui
falando da teoria se você não consegue
medir isso na prática, né? Então vamos
tentar ajudar da melhor forma possível,
porque os exames mais ortodoxos não
ajudam aqui. Então na abordagem
funcional a gente trabalha com dados
concretos na medida do possível. Então o
primeiro exame e talvez o mais completo
disponível no Brasil é o teste de áos
orgânicos urinários. Aí você vai ter
algumas empresas que trabalham com isso.
Vou dar exemplos aqui. Great Pls que tem
uma sucursal lá em Salvador. Você tem o
Origolab que tem aqui sede aqui em São
Paulo. Você tem o
Prision Labs também que aqui em São
Paulo, tá? Então essas empresas eles
mandam material para os Estados Unidos,
né? O teste de orgânicos urinários.
Então o exame mede mais de 70 marcadores
metabólicos. incluindo metabólitos
intermediários do ciclo de crebes.
Quando então você vê elevações de ácido
málico, do ácido sucínico, do ácido
fumárico, do ácido alfa cetoglutárico,
são marcadores na urina, são marcadores
metabólicos, tá? Você tá vendo
evidências diretas de que o ciclo de
créditos não está rodando do jeito que
deveria, né? O suxinato e o fumarato
elevados, inclusive são reconhecidos
como moléculas sinalizadoras que podem
ativar
vias inflamatórias quando liberadas da
mitocôndria. Então o investimento desses
exames não é muito barato, mas é por
volta de R$ 2.000, R$ 2.500,
mas para pessoas que estão muito
cansadas, estão muito esgotadas, que
estão com uma doença que nenum nenhum
médico resolve, vale muito a pena fazer
esse tipo de exame, tá? Hã, mas existe
exames mais acessíveis que pode fazer em
qualquer laboratório, tá? Qual o que
seria o lactato
e o piruvato séricos? Isso dá para
fazer, e a relação lactato piruvato.
Então, quando as mitocôndrias não estão
funcionando direito, o metabolismo
energético desvia paraa via glicolítica,
tá? Que que é glicolítico? Quebrar
glicose para formar energia, tá? Então é
glicolítico anaeróbico, ou seja, que não
usa oxigênio, tá? E essa via produz esse
marcador lactato.
Então, uma relação lactato piruvato
aumentada, ou seja, tem mais lactato do
que piruvato, especialmente acima de 20
para um, é sinal de disfunção na
fosforilação oxidativa. O diferencial
dessa relação é que ela distingue
defeitos da cadeia respiratória
mitocondrial de outras causas de acidose
láctica, como é o caso da deficiência da
piruvat deshidrogenase, que é um enzima,
tá? Então tem pessoas que têm esse
problema de nascença ou mesmo a
deficiência de piruvato carboxilase.
Nesses dois casos, a relação
do lactato com piruvato permanece
normal. Então esse exame particularmente
ele não é não é caro, ele geralmente
custa menos de R$ 100 a dosagem do
lactato que eu tô falando, tá? Você pode
também pedir a creatina quinas, que é o
marcador menos importante, porque se
você fizer exercício, por exemplo, esse
marcador sobe, então ele é meio assim,
eh, qualquer coisinha que acontece de
você fazer uma atividade física, ele
pode subir, mas também ele é barato,
você faz em qualquer laboratório por
menos de R$ 50. Se você tiver uma
elevação persistente de creatina
quinase, que a sigla dele é secar sem
explicação, como é o caso do treino, né,
um treino intenso a princípio, isso pode
indicar também doença mitocondrial
muscular, tá? Ou miopatia mitocondrial.
Então ele é um marcador indireto que
pode ajudar no contexto clínico
apropriado. E você pode medir também a
coenzima Q10 do sangue. Não é um exame
de rotina, não é coberto por planos, mas
tem e boa parte dos laboratórios, tá?
Que que é coenzima Q10? Eu acho que
vocês sabem mais ou menos o que é, mas
ela é uma substância essencial pra
cadeia transportadora de elétrons, tá?
parte da fosforização oxidativa. Então
ela vai atuar no complexo um e no
complexo três. Níveis baixos de cozema
que 10 no sangue podem indicar eh que
existe uma disfunção mitocondrial. Então
o que que pode baixar a cozemaquedes?
Você sabe, né? As estatinas, né?
Rosvastatina, cinvastatina,
atorvastatina, pitavastatina.
Então essas substâncias vão atrapalhar a
via do mevalonato, que além de produzir
colesterol também produz com coenzima
Q10. Então quando você usa estatina ela
vai baixar o nível de coenzima Q10 e vai
causar fraqueza muscular e doença
muscular. Inclusive, muitas pessoas
ficam com dores musculares. Então,
laboratórios maiores geralmente fazem o
exame de cozima, que é 10 e ele é mais
carinho, ele tá entre R$ 300 e R$ 500 só
esse exame. Então, estudos enfatizam
que medir a coenzima Q10 ou CO10 pros
íntimos, né, nas células de defesa, os
leucostos, pode refletir melhor eh o do
que o sangue para saber as concentrações
teciduais.
Mas se você conseguir já medir no
sangue, já dá para ajudar, já dá para
ter um direcionamento, tá? Então
sequenciamento completo do DA
mitocondrial não tá disponível assim com
facilidade, já tem no Brasil, mas só em
poucos laboratórios especializados, é o
caso do Fleuri, do Mendéix, do Genômica
e do Genero. Então eles já fazem
sequenciamento de DNA mitocondrial.
Então o DNA mitocondrial ele é dado
exclusivamente das mães, tá? Isso é uma
característica interessante do DA
mitocondrial. Já falei isso em vídeos
anteriores no canal. Então você pode
avaliar mutações patogênicas específicas
e especialmente é útil quando você tá
suspeitando uma doença mitocondrial
primária de nascença, ou seja, genética,
tá?
Então esse exame do DNA mitocondrial,
ele é só útil quando você tá despeitando
de uma doença mitocondrial de nascença
ou hereditária ou genética, tá? E é bem
carinho, é entre 2.000 e R$ 10.000,
dependendo do painel que você for fazer.
Também você pode tá vendo marcadores
indiretos que qualquer laboratório vai
fazer, que é o cisteína, que é vai medir
mais metilação e inflamação, vitaminas
em geral, né, B1, B2, B3, B6, B12 e
ácido fólico. Na minha experiência, o
B6, aliás, o B12 e o B9, que é o ácido
fólico, qualquer laboratório faz, mas a
B1, B2, B3, B6 é um pouquinho mais
difícil, tá? Então, essas vitaminas são
cofatores essenciais para as enzimas do
ciclo de crebes e da cadeia
respiratória.
E deficiências podem comprometer
diretamente a fosforização
oxidativa. Então, o magnésio, muito
importante, vocês sabem disso, ele é
necessário para mais de 300 reações
enzimáticas, incluindo várias reações
mitocondriais. O magnésio, ele é um
cofator essencial para quê? para ATP
sintase, que é a enzima que forma a o
ATP, OK? Então, precisa muito de
magnésio para formar energia, tá? Quando
você não tem magnésio, não tem energia.
Então, o problema é que o magnésio do
sangue ele não reflete, já falei isso em
vídeos, acho que vocês já viram, esse
magnésio cérico não reflete estoques
intracelulares,
já que o magnésio está dentro da célula.
99% dele do magnésio total corporal é
intracelular, não é? no sangue, não fica
boiando o sangue, tá? Então é importante
às vezes você medir o magnésio dentro da
célula vermelha, o magnésio
eritrocitário, ele é muito mais preciso,
OK? Mas na falta dele você pode estar
usando aquela questão lá de quartis.
Você pede o magnésio do sangue sérico,
vê se tá no primeiro, no segundo
quartil, se tiver no primeiro e segundo,
não tá legal. Tem que est no no terceiro
ou quarto quartis, tá?
Se vocês não souberem o que que é
quartis, eu explico aqui eh em algum
momento.
Também é possível medir aminoácidos do
sangue, aminoácidos plasmáticos. E se
você tiver elevação de alanina, tá?
Alanina é aminoácido, isso pode indicar
disfunção mitocondrial, porque a lanina
é o produto da transaminação de piruvato
pela alanina aminotrosferase, tá? Que
também conhecido como TGP.
Então, estudos do ano passado mostraram
que a lanina, seguida da glutamina e
tirosina
são as anormalidades de aminoácidos mais
frequentes em pacientes com defeito da
cadeia respiratória. Então, tem já tem
laboratórios maiores fazendo o perfil
completo de aminoácidos, que é o
aminoácidograma, né? Se eu não me
engano, eu já vi várias vezes esse
exame, especialmente colegas pedindo
esse tipo de exame, mas com os exames
disponíveis aqui, né, mesmo que você não
tenha acesso ao aminoácidograma,
você pode estar vendo, né, eh, a partes
desse processo aí da função
mitocondrial, tá? Então, recapitulando,
quais são os exames? Ios orgânicos
urinários.
Esses são aqueles exames que eu falei
que é por volta de 2000 2500 que vai
paraos Estados Unidos, que tem o
Origolab, tem o o
Great Ples e tem o Precision, a lactato
piruvato, lactato piruvato qualquer
laboratório faz a medidas de comenza,
que é 10 que o plano não cobre, mas
também
é presente nos laboratórios grandes, a
medida da CPK ou Calquer laboratório
tem,
o DNA mitocondrial, que é poucos eh
laboratórios de genética fazem e
amcisteína e magnésio, aminoácido e
vitaminas do complexo B. Dra. Ana Paula,
ela sabe que é quartil, mas ela quer que
eu explique. Mas tem mais alguém
assistindo? Porque só Paula tá falando
aqui. A Adriana não está se
manifestando. Eu não sei se ela entrou e
a Cristina Carol também não está se
manifestando. Tá, vamos lá. Que que é
quartil?
Quartil é assim.
Imagina que tem um exame que o mínimo do
exame é 10 e o máximo é 50, tá? Então,
entre 10 e 50 você divide as faixas em
quatro, tá? Então, você tem o primeiro
quartil, segundo quartil, terceiro
quartil, quarto quartil. O meio seria
exatamente o ponto que divide os quartis
inferiores dos quartis superiores.
Então, em caso assim de você não ter o
magnésio intraeletrocitário, você pode
ver se o número que aparece lá no exame
ele tá abaixo do meio do laboratório ou
acima do meio. Se ele tiver abaixo do
meio, provavelmente o magnésio da célula
vai est baixo e se tiver acima do meio,
provavelmente vai est adequado, tá? É
uma maneira mais grosseira de ver isso,
mas na ausência da possibilidade de se
fazer um magnésio intraeletrocitário.
Explica o que que são aminoácidos
essenciais. Aminoácid essenciais são os
nove aminoácidos que o seu corpo não
produz. Ele precisa tirar isso do meio
ambiente, da alimentação. Na verdade,
desses nove, dois são eh
potencialmente essenciais. O que quer
dizer isso? Que o corpo pode até
conseguir produzir, mas produz em
quantidade insuficiente, tá? Então são
nove aminoácidos que você tem que
necessariamente
obter da dieta. É como se fossem
vitaminas, tá? Do mesmo jeito que você
não produz vitamina C e nem B12, você
tem que tirar isso da alimentação. Você
tem que tirar esses aminoácidos
essenciais da alimentação também, tá? Na
verdade, eles deveriam chamar vitaminas,
por algum motivo não chama assim.
Ácidos, orgânicos urinários, lactato,
piruvato, coisa, que 10. Tá anotando aí?
Obrigado, T Paulo. Você é muito gentil.
Muito gentil. Eu tenho noção.
Noção do quê? Cristina, me explica se
quis dizer com isso daí.
Noção do quê? Não entendi.
Bem, vamos lá. Vocês gostam de fazer
assim mensagens assim enigmáticas, né,
soltas assim, que a gente não sabe do
que vocês estão falando, né? É engraçado
isso.
Mas vamos lá, já que tocamos no assunto
na cois 10 como marcador essencial. né?
Também é um suplemento essencial para
boa parte das pessoas, especialmente as
que tomam coisema, perdão, as que tomam
estatinas, né, que tem deficiência
comema Q10.
Eh, vale a pena abrir um parêntese muito
importante aqui. Então, muitas vezes a
gente fala de energia mitocondrial de
forma abstrata, mas existe uma célula no
corpo masculino que é basicamente um
motor com uma cauda, né? Eu acho que tão
começando a entender o que eu tô falando
aqui, onde a falha mitocondrial
significa o fim da linha genética, né?
Adivinharam do que eu tô falando? Então
vamos falar aqui sobre um dos
suplementos mais subestimados para a
fertilidade masculina, no caso, né? Esse
botozinho é a causa do espermatozóide.
Então a cozima Q10, pouca a gente sabe,
mas ele é um excelente suplemento para
fertilidade, tá?
E eu vou direto ao ponto. Teve uma
metaanálise publicada em agosto de 2025
no World Journal of Man's Health, que
mostrou que homens inférteis que
suplementaram com 10 tiveram seis vezes
mais chances de gravidez comparado ao
placebo. Olha só, gente. OS ratio de
6,02.
Isso é muito significante do ponto de
vista estatístico para quem tende,
entende um pouquinho de estatística.
Então, mas antes de você sair comprando
qualquer coisa que é 10 por aí, eu
preciso explicar para você exatamente
como esse composto funciona no sistema
reprodutor masculino, qual que é a forma
ideal, a dosagem correta e porque a
maioria das pessoas está usando errado.
Dana Paula,
eh, esperando as novidades que o Dr. vai
trazer vai trazer o congresso de
medicina integrativa e funcional. Ela tá
falando do congresso de medicina
integrativa lá do de Portugal que eu vou
estar participando semana que vem, no
qual ele irá palestrar sobre protocolo
Recode. Parabéns pelo convite, tá?
Obrigado, viu? Muito obrigado. Então,
vai ter esse evento, eh, se eu não me
engano, é dia 6 e 7 de dezembro, mas eu
vou para lá dia 2 e chego lá dia 3 de
dezembro. Então, vai ter esse congresso
lá na cidade de Porto. Eu vou participar
e vou dar a palestra sobre o protocolo
recode reversing cognitive decline, ou
seja, o protocolo de reversão do
cognitivo, o protocolo do Alzheimer, tá?
Então, gente, isso é muito importante,
pouca gente sabe disso, fora da área
médica. A infertilidade masculina
responde por aproximadamente
50% dos casos de infertilidade de casal,
tá? Então, 50% dos casos, ou o homem é
único culpado ou ele é parcialmente
culpado, tá? Eu acho que hoje em dia o
homem é culpado de tudo, né? Mas vamos
lá. Na parte de infertilidade, pelo
menos essa parte é 50%, né? Então, 50%
dos casos de infertilidade eh conjugal,
o homem tem alguma participação. E aqui
está o dado que pouca gente sabe, o
estresse oxidativo do semen é
considerado o principal fator na
formação, ou seja, na patogênese da
infetilidade masculina idiopática.
Então, estamos falando aqui de radicais
livres, atacando diretamente o DNA do
espermatozoide,
danificando a membrana desse
espummatozóide e comprometendo o quê? A
motilidade, movimento. Então, o
espermatozoide é uma célula extremamente
vulnerável. Diferente de outras células
do corpo, ele tem quantidade mínima de
citoplasma, o que significa capacidade
antioxidante endógena bem limitada.
Além disso, a membrana espermatozoide é
rica em ácidos gros polinsaturados, o
mesmo lado do ômega-3. Olha que
engraçado.
E esses ácidos grassos polinsaturados,
eles são alvos fáceis para peroooxidação
lipídica, que é uma forma de estresse
oxidativo, tá? Então é como ter um
tanque de combustível sem tampa.
Qualquer faísca vai causar uma explosão,
vai causar um dano. Então é exatamente
aqui que entra com enzima Q10. Então, a
coeximaquedes atua em dois níveis.
Primeiro, como transportadora de
elétrons na cadeia respiratória
mitocondrial, essencial paraa produção
de ATP, que é a energia que o
espermatozoide precisa para nadar.
Então, segundo, na forma reduzida, o
bikquinol, ou seja, o a forma da cozema
que é 10 que está ali a ponto de bala
para ser antioxidante, né? Tem a forma o
biquinon, né? Forma biquinol. A forma
bquinol é a forma reduzida e a
bikquinona é a forma oxidada. Então a
forma reduzida do biquinol, ele funciona
como potente antioxidante liposolúvel.
Ele protege as membranas celulares
contra esse efeito de peroxidação, que é
um tipo de estresse oxidativo.
Então vamos aos números.
A metaanálise de BACRE e colaboradores
que foi publicado em 2025
no World Journal of Menou
nove ensaios clínicos randomizados com
781 participantes. Então os resultados
foram consistentes. Aumento médio de
10,2 milhões de patozóides por ml na
concentração esperemática, melhora de 5%
na motilidade total, aumento de 0,1
ml do volume seminal e o mais
importante, aumento de 37 ng por mil nos
níveis seminais, ou seja, do semmen de
cozima Q10. Então, outro dado
crucial veio da metaálise de AKGB, que
foi publicado no Frontiers em
Farmacology em janeiro desse ano, em que
foi analisado, foram analisados oito
ensaios clínicos com 877 homens
encontraram não apenas melhora nos
parâmetros espermáticos, mas também
alterações hormonais significativas,
aumento da testosterona sérica, aumento
da inibina B de bola.
Simultaneamente houve redução de LH FSH,
o que sugere que houve melhora da função
testicular primária, não apenas
compensação do eixo hipotálam hipófe.
Então aqui tá um ponto que vai
diferenciar quem entende do assunto de
quem só repete informação superficial. A
análise subgrupos desse estudo mostrou
que o tratamento por mais de 3 meses foi
necessário
para melhorar significativamente a
morfologia do esperma, tá? Então, menos
de 3 meses houve alguma melhora na
concentração e motilidade, ou seja, mais
quantidade deatoide e mais movimento,
mas a forma morfologia não mudou. Então
tem que ter paciência na hora de usar
esses suplementos. eles não são de ação
muito rápida.
Então, lembrando também que isso faz
todo o sentido biológico, porque a
esperogênese,
que é a formação completa do
espermatozóide, leva por volta de 74
dias, tá? A gente na prática clínica a
gente sempre pensa em 90 dias para
simplificar, mas o tempo é por volta de
74. Então, se você quer
impactar espumatozoides desde o início
da formação, precise pelo menos um ciclo
completo, então seria aí grosseiramente
90 dias, né? Vamos falar de dosagem. A
dosagem mais usada é de 200 mg de
coenzima Q10, mas comenzima Q10 é muito
seguro até em doses muito altas, tá?
Alguns protocolos usaram doses mais
altas até 600 mg divididos em duas ou
três tomadas, né? Mas isso começa a
encarecer o tratamento, né? Protocolo
que eu uso aqui na clínica, na maioria
das vezes, é 200 mg de biquinol por dia,
duas vezes ao dia, quando a pessoa pode
adquirir o biquinol, senão a gente pode
passar até o biquinona, mas como eu
falei, a forma o biquinol reduzida é
mais potente, tá? que não depende do
organismo transformar o biquinona na
forma reduzida.
Então você pode estar tomando 200 a 400
mg por dia de biquinol para a
fertilidade masculina por no mínimo 4
meses antes da tentativa de engravidar.
Ok? E por que que o biquenol e não
biquinona, né? Porque a biquinona é a
forma oxidada. Ela precisa ser
convertida no organismo em um biquinol
para exercer a função antioxidante.
Então, em homens acima de 40, essa
conversão ela é menor, é menos intensa,
menos eficiente. Então, o biquinol ele
já tá pronto na formativa reduzida,
então não precisa fazer esse processo no
organismo. A biodisponibilidade é bem
maior também. Alguns estudos mostram que
é até oito vezes mais absorção comparada
ao bikinol. Então isso aqui também é,
tem hora que eu leio artigo falando que
tem que ser o bikinol, tem hora que eu
vejo o artigo falando que pode ser o
biquona. Isso é um pouco confuso, tá
pessoal? Mas na dúvida,
se você tem o recurso, adquire na forma
de biquinol, tá? Mas se não tiver cão,
caça com gato, né? Pessoal, vou pegar um
pouquinho de água lá e já volto, tá? Eu
tô com a boca seca já aqui.
Me deem só um instante.
[Música]
Pronto, estou de volta.
Mais alguém quer fazer um comentário?
Eu
acho que o pessoal é muito tímido ou
então não tem ninguém assistindo.
Tô Ana Paula tá bastante eloquente aqui,
mas os outros não estão. Vamos lá. Deixa
eu abrir aqui minha água.
Voltando ao estudo, a metanálise, né?
Nas análises de subgrupo, os benefícios
persistiram
nas formulações multiingredientes,
mas nem sempre quando a coisema Q10 foi
usada sozinha. Então isso tem o quê?
Isso tem a questão do sinergismo, né,
com outros antioxidantes. Então, teve
uma metaanálise de NEIL e colaboradores
que foi publicada na Reproductive
Science em setembro de 25 e comparou
diretamente com enzima com elitina em
homens com infertilidade que não tinha
explicação e o resultado. Então, a
combinação do com enzima Q1 com el
carnetina foi superior para aumentar a
concentração esperática. E a Carnetina
foi superior para melhorar a motilidade
progressiva, tá? Então é bom usar os
dois juntos. Coisima que é 10 com el
Carnetina. Seja bem-vindo, Neusa Lúcia.
Neusa Lúcia, né?
Agora eu não sei se ela entrou na live
ou só ela só tá aparecendo aqui porque
ela se inscreveu agora na comunidade.
Vamos continuar aqui. Então, o protocolo
que eu uso muito aqui na clínica é o
biquinol 200 mg duas vezes ao dia. Ele
carnina 2 g por dia, divididos em duas
tomadas.
Aí você pode associarl carnetina, que é
o que entra no cérebro, 1 g por dia. O
zinco queelado 30 mg dia. O selênio 200
microg uma vez ao dia. Vitamina E na
forma de tocotrienois
ou mix de tocoferóis com tocotrenóis,
400 unidades na forma então de das oito
vitam vitâmeros, né, como eu falei.
Então, por que que essa combinação
específica? Então, a elcarnitina
ela transporta
grassos para dentro da mitocôndria, né?
Então essa função principal da
elcarnitina, trabalha em conjunto com a
cozema que 10 na produção de energia e a
cetil alicarnitina tem melhor penetração
no tecido testicular.
O zinco, tá vendo que a ctiole canitina
não é só cérebro, também tem maior
penetração no testículo. E o zinco, ele
é cofator de mais de 300 enzimas,
incluindo as envolvidas na síntese de
testosterona e de maturação espermática.
E o selênio ele é componente da colutina
peroxidase e é fundamental para proteção
antioxidante.
E a vitamina E na forma de tocoferides e
tocotrenóis protege as membranas
lipídicas e recicla a coenzima quedés
que foi oxidada para ela voltar de volta
na forma obikquinol, que é a forma
reduzida.
Bem, timing, a coisa Q10 é lipossolúvel,
então ela deve ser tomada com refeições
que contenham gordura.
Para melhor absorção, eu recomendo tomar
com café da manhã, com ovos, né, ou
abacate. E também no jantar. A el
cararnetina pode ser tomada em jejum ou
com refeições, porque a absorção não é
muito diferente com barriga vazia ou
cheia. E para homens que são submetidos
a técnica de reprodução assistida,
é bom iniciar o protocolo pelo menos 3
meses antes da coleta de sem para fazer
o X ou FIV. Que que é X? Ixi é aquela
técnica mais avançada que injeta um
esmatozoide e um óvulo, né, com uma
micropipeta. E o FIV é aquela
fertilização em vitro que você coloca um
montezóide numa placa de pétrico, um
monte de óvulo, tá? Então são duas técem
artificial. Então os estudos mostram que
mesmo em caso de X, né, onde
tecnicamente selecionamos um únicoide, a
qualidade desse matozóide ainda importa
pro desenvolvimento embrionário. Então a
evidência tá se acumulando e quer dizer
que essas técnicas aí de utilizar
nutracuticos para melhorar a fertilidade
não é inimigo das técnicas de
inseminação, né? Na verdade ajuda na
inseminação, certo? Então vamos unir o
melhor dos dois mundos quando é
necessário.
Então tem três metaanálises que foram
publicadas só nesse ano de 2025 que
confirmaram o benefício da coisa
maquedia na fertilidade masculina.
Então, não é mais uma questão de se
funciona, mas de como otimizar o uso. E
a resposta está nos detalhes: a forma
correta de suplemento, a dosagem
adequada, duração suficiente e a
combinação sinégérgica com outros
nutrientes.
Agora, se a gente cuida da usina de
energia, que é a mitocôndria, nós
precisamos garantir que o ambiente onde
ela trabalha não esteja tóxico. E um dos
fatores que mais inibe a função
mitocondrial e que promove o câncer é a
acidez do terreno biológico, tá? Então
esse é um assunto que vocês pediram para
eu falar, que é a questão da do uso do
bicarbonato.
Bem, vou perguntar aqui para vocês.
Você sente um cansaço muscular que não
passa, uma inflamação que parece nunca
ceder, ou talvez você esteja lutando
contra uma doença autoimune que os
médicos dizem que é crônico, incurável?
Pois bem, um estudo publicado no Journal
of Immunology em 2018 descobriu algo que
vai te surprender. Uma substância que
você provavelmente tem na sua cozinha,
que você usa aí, uma coisa banal e que
pode reprogramar o seu sistema imune em
apenas duas semanas. Eu tô falando sim
do bicarbonato de sódio que é usado na
culinária e também é usado muito no
mundo esportivo, né? E não é aquela
conversa de cura milagrosa que a gente é
muito sério no que diz, né? Hoje eu vou
te mostrar exatamente o que a ciência
séria, ciência séria descobriu sobre
essa molécula, desde como ela preserva
os seus músculos e os ossos até como ela
tá sendo usada em protocolos oncológicos
com resultados impressionantes.
Ó, mais comentários da Dra. Ana Paula.
Percebo que a maioria, tipo 90% dos meus
pacientes estão com zinco baixo. É bem
comum mesmo. Fontes de erntina tem é
mais carne, tá?
Eh, que mais e frutos do mar, peixes,
tá? São fontes boas de errina.
Apesar de que para quem tá muito cansado
é melhor suplementar diretamente.
Bem, antes de mais nada, eu preciso
contar uma coisa para vocês. O
bicarbonato de sódio
passou décadas
sendo ignorado pela medicina ortodoxa
como se fosse apenas o antiácido comum
de farmácia.
Então era considerado uma coisa de vó.
Mas a verdade é que pesquisadoras de
universidades como a Medical College of
Georgia e o Morphet Cancer Center estão
redescobrindo essa molécula,
encontrando mecanismo de ação que
ninguém imaginava. E é isso que eu quero
compartilhar contigo, com vocês hoje.
Para você entender porque que o
bicarbonato pode fazer tanta diferença,
precisa primeiro compreender um conceito
fundamental. o seu corpo trabalhar duro,
bem duro, para manter o pH dele bem
estabilizado, uma faixa bem estreita
entre 7,35 e 745 de pH. Então, quando há
um desvio disso, isso vai comprometer a
estrutura das proteínas, a função das
enzimas, a integridade das células. Por
isso que é muito, muito importante o
corpo manter o pH. Então, é questão de
vida ou morte literalmente. Então,
o seu corpo tem dois grandes sistemas de
defesa para manter o pH. do sangue
adequado. Os pulmões eles regulam gás
carbônico em questão de minutos, né?
Quando você hiperventila
é um mecanismo para poder liberar o
ácido que tá no sangue, OK? Para
combater uma acidose metabólica com
alcalose respiratória, tá? Já os rins
eles regulam o bicarbonato reabsorvendo
ou fabricando mais dele quando
necessário, só que esse processo leva
horas ou até dias. Então, a respiração é
muito rápido e o rim já é mais demorado.
Bem, agora vem o pulo do gato. A
medicina ortodoxa eles se preocupam com
acidose franca, aquela acidose que a
pessoa tá quase morrendo na UTI, aquela
que aparece nos exames de sangue, né? O
pH tá abaixo de 7,35, é o caso, por
exemplo, da cetooacidose diabética.
Mas existe um estado silencioso traiço
chamado acidose metabólica latente ou
subclínica. Nesse estado, o pH do sangue
parece normal nos exames, por exemplo,
7.38 38 parece estar tudo bem, só que
esse número que está normal está sendo
mantido às custas de um sacrifício
enorme. Então, seu corpo está degradando
os ossos, está pegando o magnésio dos
ossos e o cálcio dos ossos para poder
usar como tampão. Então, ele pega
cálcio, pega magnésio e pega fosfato.
Então, tá degradando os músculos para
liberar também glutamina dos músculos
para utilizar nos rins, que é o rim
utiliza para excretar o ácido. Então é
como se você estivesse pagando uma
dívida destruindo a sua própria casa,
né? Então é como se você tivesse
vendendo a casa inteira para pagar uma
dívida.
E de onde vem essa carga ácida crônica?
Da dieta ocidental.
Proteínas animais.
e grãos geram ácido sulfúrico e também o
ácido fosfórico. Quando são
metabolizados, frutas e vegetais, por
outro lado, são precursores de
bicarbonato, então tem que ter um
equilíbrio entre as proteínas e grãos e
frutas e vegetais, tá?
Quando a balança pede, pende, né, demais
pro lácido, pro lado ácido, o seu corpo
paga o preço. E aqui entra o bicarbonato
como uma estratégia pragmática para
poupar essa estrutura corporal. Então,
deixa te contar o que acontece no mundo
do esporte de alto rendimento, que nada
mais é do que um estresse metabólico
também, né? Porque é ali que os
mecanismos ficam ainda mais claros.
Então, quando você faz um exercício
intenso, tipo um sprint, né, uma corrida
rápida de 400 m ou uma luta de judô, a
demanda de energia excede a capacidade
das suas mitocôndrias de produzir ATP
com oxigênio. Então, seu corpo apela pra
glicólise anaeróbica, que eu já falei
aqui nessa live, que é a quebra de
glicose na célula sem usar oxigênio.
Então o problema é que isso vai gerar
lactato, eu já comentei, né?
E principalmente os íons de hidrogênio.
Então esses prótons, esses íons de
hidrogênios vão acumular dentro do
músculo. O pH vai despencar, vai ficar
baixo,
as enzimas vão travar e você vai
fatigar. Então é aquela sensação de
queimação tão comum que a gente tem
quando a gente faz assim uma musculação
muito intensa, né? Então você vai ter
aquela sensação de queimação que te
obriga a parar. Então bbonato de sódio
aumenta a capacidade de tamponamento do
sangue. Ele não entra diretamente no
músculo, mas cria um gradiente que
facilita a saída dos prótons da célula
muscular para o plasma.
Então é como se abrisse uma válvula de
escape para esse ácido tá acumulando no
músculo. Então metaanálises mostram
melhorias de 2 a 3% em desempenho
em eventos entre 30 segundos e 12
minutos. Isso parece pouco, mas em
competição de elite faz toda a diferença
entre o pódio e o oitavo lugar, né?
principalmente em esportes como natação.
Mas agora vem a parte que realmente me
fascina e que valida algumas alegações
da medicina alternativa, né, dita
alternativa que antes eram descartadas
como bobagem. A pesquisa do Dr. Paul ou
Conor mostrou que o bicarbonato sódio
pela boca, né, via oral, ativa uma via
antiinflamatória no seu corpo de uma
forma completamente inesperada. Funciona
assim, quando você ingere a solução de
bicarbonato, neutraliza o ácido
estômago. Então, as células mesoteliais
que revestem os órgãos internos, como o
caso do basso, detectam essa mudança no
ambiente.
E aqui está o dado surpreendente. Essas
células se comunicam com o tecido do
basso usando acetilcolina, como se fosse
neurônios.
Elas então ativam a chamada via
colinésica antiinflamatória. Então o
resultado final é uma reprogramação dos
macrófagos no baço. Então os macrófos
podem assumir dois estados principais.
estado M1, que é o modo de ataque, o
modo agressivo, que vai liberar
citocinas inflamatórias, como é o caso
TNF alfa e terocina 6, que é muito
importante esse estado M1 para combater
infecções,
mas em excesso causa estragos nas
doenças autoimunes. Então o estado M2 é
o estado de deixadiço, né? é o modo de
reparo, liberando telefina 10
antiformatória e promovendo a resolução
da informação. Então, tem um estudo
que foi publicado no Journal of
Immunology que mostrou que o consumo de
bicarbonato promoveu um desvio robusto
de M1 para M2, ou seja, acalmou as
células imune. Então, em modelos animais
de pressão alta e doença renal crônica,
isso resultou
em proteção renal significativa. E em
voluntários humanos saudáveis que
tomaram aproximadamente 2 g por dia de
bicarbonato durante duas semanas, o
mesmo padrão foi observado nas células
do sangue periférico.
O corpo interpreta o sinal alcalino como
um estado de segurança pós-prandial,
reduzindo a reatividade autoimune.
Isso abre portas para condições como
artrite hematoide e lupus.
Agora eu preciso falar sobre o tema mais
polêmico, que é o bicarbonato em relação
ao câncer. E aqui é fundamental separar
o joio do trigo. A teoria do Túlio Simon
Cine, tá, de que o câncer é um fungo e
que o pessoal realmente cai matando
e que injeções de bicarbonato vão curar
ao matar a Cândida, isso não tem como
fazer sentido, tá pessoal? é
biologicamente insustentável,
é implausível e pode ser até perigoso.
Então, pessoas morreram já de alcalose
metabólica, que é o contrário de acidose
metabólica, severa porque tomaram
excesso de bicarbonato, tá? Então é
muito sério isso. Câncer é uma doença
mitocondrial, tá? Principalmente
mitocondrial, mas também é uma doença de
certa forma genética também,
secundariamente genética.
Não tem nada a ver com micose, só que
tem alguns fungos sim que são causas de
câncer, tá? Mas não é a mesma coisa. No
entanto,
a intuição, né, não é bem intuição,
porque isso é falado desde o tempo do
Warberg, né, mas essa informação que os
tumores são ácidos, ela está correta. O
meio ambiente que os as células tumorais
estã em volta dessas células tumoral é
ácido, tá? porque elas fazem muita
glicosa anaeróbica na maior parte das
vezes, tá? Então, células cancerígenas
preferem a glicólise fermentativa, ou
seja, anaeróbica, mesmo na presença de
oxigênio. É o famoso efeito Warburger.
Isso exporta lactato e prótons, que são
H+, né? são hidrogênios para o espaço
extracelular, cria um ambiente, no caso,
microambiente tumoral ácido. Aí o
pessoal confunde demais isso, gente. Não
é que o sangue fica ácido, gente, não é
isso, tá? Pensa bem, nosso corpo tem
vários compartimentos. Tem sangue, tem
linfa, tem líqu, tem saliva, tem urina,
tem um monte de ambiente, tá? E aqui nós
estamos falando do microambiente em
volta do tumor, tá? Não é o sangue
táácido, tá gente? Por favor, eu sei que
é difícil vocês entenderem isso, mas não
é se vocês pensarem bem.
Então esse microambiente tumoral ele é
ácido porque as células tumorais
preferencialmente vão queimar a glicose
sem usar o oxigênio e vão formar lactato
e vão formar íons de hidrogênio que vão
pro extracelular em volta do tumor e vai
deixar o pH em volta dele bem ácido
entre 6,5 e 6,9. De novo, é o pH de 6,5
6,9
em volta das células tumorais. Não tem
nada a ver com sangue, isso, tá bom? E
essa acidez não é acidental, ela é uma
estratégia de sobrevivência do tumor. O
astro ele paralisa as células T killer,
as titotósicas,
tá? E também as células natural killer,
que deveriam atacar o câncer. Então é um
jeito que o tumor também encontra para
se defender da célula de defesa. Então
tem vários quimioteráficos
que são, por incrível que pareça, eles
são bases, são alcalinas, né? são bases
fracas
e não consegue penetrar na célula
cancerígena nesse ambiente ácido. Elas
ficam aprisionadas do lado de fora.
Então o ácido ele ainda ativa enzimas
que degradam a matriz celular, abrindo
caminho paraa metástase. Então, o ácido
em volta do tumor protege ele contra a
ação de células de defesa e atrapalha a
ação dos quimioterápicos
e ainda facilita as metástases. Então, a
prova mais robusta de que manipular esse
pH funciona vem dos ensaios tilateis
para carcinoma patocelular que é de
fígado.
A químioembolização
transarterial é padrão para câncer de
fígado inop, ou seja, que não dá para
operar. Então, pesquisadores chineses
modificaram o protocolo para incluir
injeção local de bicarbonato de sódio a
5%
diretamente na artéria que alimenta o
tumor. Olha que interessante, tá?
O resultado foi impressionante.
Taxa de resposta objetiva de 100% para
tumores grandes tratados com protocolo
modificado comparado a 44 a 63% do grupo
controle. Então, a administração local
superou a limitação da dose oral,
neutralizando a acidose intratumoral,
sem causar calose sistêmica perigosa,
tá? Porque se tivessem dado todo esse
bicarbonato pela boca, a pessoa ia
entrar em alcalose e poderia até morrer.
Então, a solução foi administrar o
bicarbonato diretamente na artéria que
nutre o tumor, né? Isso ajudou demais,
neutralizou a acidose intratumoral.
E tem mais, estudos pré-clínicos no
Morfit Cancer Center investigam se o
bicarbonato oral pode potencializar
imunoterapias, como é o caso inibidores
de checkpoint, que é uma coisa super
cara, super moderna, tá? Então, em
modelos de melanoma e câncer
pancreático, a suplementação oral elevou
o pH tumoral, ou seja, deixou o pH mais
alcalino e aumentou a infiltração de
células T de defesa, transformando
tumores imunologicamente frios, né? Ou
seja, que não estavam respondendo a
terapia imune em tumores quentes que
estavam respondendo a terapia imune.
Então, vou contar para vocês agora sobre
longevidade.
Existe um gênico com nome esquisito,
chama cloto, K.
Ele é um regulador mestre do
envelhecimento.
Então, camundongos deficientes nesse
gene cloto apresenta um fenótipo de
envelhecimento acelerado com
arteriosclerose,
osteoporose, calcificação de tecidos e
morte precoce. Então, um estudo
fascinante mostrou que a suplementação
de bicarbonato na água bebida por esses
camundongos aumentou a expectativa de
vida média de 78 dias para 127 dias.
Então, teve um aumento de
aproximadamente 60% de longevidade. O
bicarbonato não restaurou o gene, mas
mitigou as consequências ruins
metabólicas da sua ausência,
especificamente a retenção de fosfato e
a acidose.
Em humanos idosos, a acidose metabólica
de baixo grau
é comum pelo declínio natural da função
renal. Então, estudos clínicos mostram
que corrigir essa acidose leve com
suplementação de bicarbonato resulta em
preservação muscular, reduzindo
catabolismo proteico, proteção óssea,
diminuindo a reabsorção.
Então, isso é a validação científica
do conceito de poupar a estrutura
corporal do custo metabólico da
homeostase do pH.
Agora eu preciso que vocês tenham
atenção máxima, segurança e interações
medicamentosas. Eu acho que eu vou me
aproximar um pouquinho mais do microfone
para baixar o meu tom de voz.
O bicarbonato ele não é inofensivo, OK?
Tem que tomar muito cuidado com o
bicarbonato. Então não é porque ele é
uma coisa que tem na cozinha, que você
compra no supermercado, é que ele é
tranquilão, qualquer dose tá valendo,
tá?
Então,
o uso crônico indiscriminado,
especialmente combinado com suplementos
de cálcio, pode levar uma síndrome
chamado leite álcale, tá? Que leva a
hipercalcemia, ou seja, excesso de
cálcio no sangue, alcalose metabólica,
lesão renal aguda. Então, pode acontecer
o quê? Deposição de cálcio nos rins,
nefalcinosa, né, que a gente chama,
levando a falência renal irreversível.
Tá? Então, uma colher de chá de
bicarbonato tem cerca de 100 mg de
sódio, tá? Cuidado com isso.
Para quem tem hipertensão, pressão alta,
insuficiência cardíaca ou insuficiência
renal e tem sensibilidade ao sódio, tem
um gênismo que define se você tem ou não
tem sensibilidade ao sódio para
desenvolver hipertensão relacionada ao
sódio. Então, quando você usa essa carga
aí de 1260 mg de sódio numa colher de
chá de bicarbonato, isso pode ser uma
carga de sódio problemática para algumas
pessoas, tá? Tem o detalhe, o
bicarbonato também interage com vários
medicamentos, ele aumenta os níveis no
sangue e também a minha vida do caso das
anfetaminas, né, que hoje no Brasil é
muito difícil você encontrar legalmente,
mas tem muita gente que toma ainda
underground para emagrecimento
e também pode aumentar a meia vida do
venvance, né, que é muito usado aí pra
hiperatividade, né, transtorno de
hiperatividade, déficit de atenção.
Então, ao alcalinizar a urina, isso pode
causar aumento da toxicidade dessas
anfetaminas. E também a o bicarbonato,
ele vai reduzir a eficácia da aspirina
porque aumenta a excreção. Então, se a
pessoa tá tomando aspirina por algum
motivo, seja por dor de cabeça ou para
efeito antiagregante plaquetário, tem
que tomar cuidado. Então,
outra coisa, o bicarbonato prejudica a
absorção de antifúng. é o caso do
cetoconasol que precisam de acidez do
estômago
e também aumenta a excreção de lítio,
podendo desestabilizar pacientes
bipolares que tomam carbonato de lítio,
tá? Então, para uso de manutenção, as
doses citadas na literatura, que eu
falei 2 g, né? Eh,
então, as doses citadas na literatura
variam de 1/4 a meia colher de chá, que
vai ser de 1,5 a 3 g, dissolvido em
água, uma, duas vezes por dia, longe das
refeições,
para não interferir na digestão, porque
para fazer digestão precisa de ácido no
estômago, tá?
Então, com as mitocôndrias cuidadas e o
terreno ácido corrigido, a gente precisa
olhar para o combustível que está
entrando nesse sistema. E nada atrapalha
mais a saúde celular do que a
desregulação da glicose e da insulina,
que é extremamente comum no consultório.
E é aqui que entra uma vitamina que na
verdade é um hormônio. Sabem do que eu
tô falando, a vitamina D de dado, né?
Então, você sabia que pessoas com
pré-diabetes que tomam vitamina D podem
estar perdendo uma chance concreta
de reverter o caminho pro diabético 2?
Um estudo publicado em agosto desse ano
na Nutrition e Metabolism
analisou dados de mais de 3800
participantes,
encontrou resultados que vão mudar a tua
estratégia com a vitamina D. Então eu
vou te mostrar exatamente as dosagens
que funcionaram, os marcadores que
melhoraram e mais importante quem
realmente se beneficia disso. Se você
tem pré-diabetes ou conhece alguém nessa
situação, os próximos minutos podem
fazer toda a diferença. Então prestem
atenção. Deixa eu te contar uma coisa
que eu vejo direto aqui no consultório.
Chega paciente com hemoglobina glicada
subindo, glicemia de jejum beirando o
limite, aquela história clássica de
pré-diabetes.
Aí vem a pergunta de sempre: "Doutor,
tem alguma coisa além de dieta que eu
possa fazer?" Pois é, lógico que tem
sim, né? A vitamina D pode ser uma peça
importante nesse quebra-cabeça
metabólico. Então, esse estudo que
acabou de sair é uma revisão
guarda-chuva conduzida por pesquisadores
na Universidade de Ciências Médicas de
Tabrites, no Irã. Olha só, Irã, gente,
até o Irã produz ciência, né? Mesmo com
aquelas confusão toda lá.
Então eles pegaram 14 metanálises
diferentes
que por sua vez incluíram 31 estudos
randomizados, controlados. Então eles
fizeram aquele estudo guarda-chuva,
juntaram várias metanálises.
Então no total foram mais de 3.800
pessoas com pré-diabetes que foram
incluídas nesses estudos combinados.
E as dosagens variaram bastante, desde
400 unidades até 60.000 1000 unidades
por semana e os estudos duraram entre
seis semanas até um ano inteiro. Então
juntou um monte de estudo que por sua
vez já estavam em várias metanálises,
tá? Então eram 31 estudos dentro de 14
metanálises nesse estudo guarda-chuva,
tá? O que juntou várias metanálises.
O que que encontraram? Bom, aqui fica
interessante. A suplementação de
vitamina D reduziu significativamente a
glicemia de jejum 0,3
mg por dcl. Os níveis de insulina em 0,1
eh microunidades por desculpa,
microunidades por ml. A hemoglobina
glicada em 0,47%
e os trigliceridos no sangue em 0,38 mg
dcl.
Então, olha só que bacana. Quanto mais
eficiente, quanto mais deficiente
vitamina D a pessoa estava no começo,
melhor foi a resposta, tá? A hemoglobina
glicada, a glicemia de jejum e a
glicemia pósprandial de 2 horas
melhoraram mais significativamente
nesses indivíduos com deficiência
prévia. Agora, antes que você pense que
a vitamina D é a solução mágica, eu
preciso te contar o outro lado.
A vitamina D não melhorou a resistência
à insulina. medida por índices
específicos, que é no caso do OMA IER,
que é uma continha que você faz com a
glicosa insulina. E também não reduziu o
índice de massa corporal MC, e é isso é
importante, não diminuiu
estatisticamente o risco de progredir de
pré-diabetes para diabetes tipo 2
franco.
Então, vitamina D tem um efeito, podemos
dizer assim, complementar
no na questão da resistência insulina,
tá? Nunca deve ser tratado pré-diabetes
só com vitamina D de dado, OK? Não deve
ser considerado panaceia.
Mas aqui fica uma pergunta que todo
mundo deveria fazer. Como diabos a
vitamina D influencia o metabolismo da
glicose? Então, deixa eu te explicar os
mecanismos que a ciência descobriu.
As células beta do pâncreas, aquelas que
produzem insulina, expressam tanto o
receptor de vitamina D de dado quanto a
enzima um alvo hidroxilase que converte
a vitamina D na sua forma ativa.
Então, um estudo publicado em janeiro de
25 no Biomedicine em Pharmacapy mostrou
que a vitamina D de dado aumenta a
secreção de insulina estimulada por
glicose
do influxo de cálcio e da regulação
positiva dos canais de cálcio voltagem
dependentes de vitamina D,
OK? voltagem positiva de células beta.
Então, quando tem deficiência em
vitamina D, a secreção de insulina fica
prejudicada.
Modelos animais comprovam isso de
maneira clara. Coelhos e camundongos
deficiente de vitamina D apresentam
secreção de insulina comprometida e a
suplementação corrige esse defeito.
Um estudo da Frontiers em Endocrinology
de 2024 demonstrou que a vitamina D
protege as células beta pancreáticas
através da via AMPK NLRP3 inflamaçoma,
prevenindo a disfunção celular induzida
por hiperglicemia, tá? Então, gente, não
vamos tratar pré-diabetes só com a
vitamina D, mas ela vai ajudar sim.
Além disso, a vitamina D, ela não age só
no pâncreas, ela age nos tecidos
periféricos,
por exemplo, nos músculos, nos
atipócios, são células de gordura, nos
hepatócitos, são as células do fígado,
porque ela melhora a sensibilidade à
insulina, tá?
Então, aumenta a secreção de insulina e
aumenta a sensibilidade de insulina.
Então, como é que ela aumenta a
sensibilidade de insulina? Primeiro, ela
vai facilitar a expressão do receptor de
insulina, melhorando a responsividade da
glicose no seu transporte, segundo
regulando metabolismo cálcio, que é
essencial pros processos intracelulares
mediados por insulina. Tem um estudo de
2024 publicado no Journal of Clinical
Endocrinology e Metabolism, que
confirmou que a vitamina D melhora a
função das células beta em pacientes com
níveis no sangue de 25 hidróxit
abaixo de 12, tá?
Então, gente com deficiência considerada
grave de vitamina D, no meu ponto de
vista, teve essa ação da vitamina D d
dado como suplemento para melhorar a
função das células betas pancreáticas,
que são as células que produzem
insulina, tá? Agora vamos falar de um
dado que considero fascinante, poucas
pessoas comentam. O grande estudo D2D,
que foi publicado New England Journal of
Medicine em 2019 acompanhou 2423
participantes com pré-diabetes que
receberam 4.000 unidades de vitamina D
por dia ou placeba, o pílodo de farinha.
Aos 24 meses, os níveis médios de
vitamina D, 25 hidróxid vitamina D, no
grupo da vitamina D suplementada subiram
para 54 comparado a 28 no placebo. E
apesar disso, não houve redução
estatisticamente significativa na
progressão pro diabetes. Então você me
pergunta, por que já que a vitamina D
seria interessante por aumentar a
secreção de insulina e também aumentar a
sensibilidade?
Porque os participantes não eram
necessariamente deficientes no início,
tá? A média basal já era de 27 ngas por
ml. E aqui tá o pulo do gato que a
maioria dos médicos ignora.
A vitamina D funciona muito melhor
quando você tá realmente deficiente para
essa finalidade, tá? para melhorar o
açúcar do sangue. Um estudo de
metanálise 2024 publicado no Journal of
Endocrine Society mostrou que pessoas
com níveis iniciais de vitamina D abaixo
de 20 tiveram 18% de chance de regressão
para a glicemia normal versus 14% do
placebo. Então a diferença foi
estaticamente significativa, ou seja,
corrigir deficiência real traz benefício
mensurável. Então, na minha experiência
clínica, eu uso a vitamina D como parte
de uma abordagem bem mais ampla para
quem tem pré-diabetes, OK?
É óbvio, vocês estão vendo aqui, pelo
que eu tô dizendo, tá longe de ser o
único pilar a vitamina D, mas é um pilar
importante para várias outras coisas,
né? Não, só para essa questão do
pré-diabetes. Então, a gente pede o
exame de 25 vitamina D no sangue e quem
tiver abaixo de 40 a gente tem que
repor, tá? Aqui vai depender do do
colega, tem gente que vai só repor se
tiver abaixo de 30,
OK? Então eu reponho para manter na
faixa entre 50 e 70, pelo menos 40, tá?
Então a dosagem vai variar muito. Se
você tá tomando vitamina D por conta,
sem acompanhamento médico, é melhor
tomar na faixa de 2.000 a 5.000 por dia.
Com acompanhamento médico pode subir
para 10.000, 20.000 por dia, tá?
Dependendo do caso.
Sempre usar a forma de colicalciferol,
vitamina D3 e não a vitamina D2, tá?
Estudos comprovam que a D3 é mais eficaz
em elevar e manter os níveis no sangue.
Então, sempre reavaliar o exame de
controle a cada três ou se meses. E,
claro, a vitamina D porcel hipossolúvel
é importante tomar junto com uma
refeição que tenha gordura para aumentar
absorção.
Mas aqui vai um ponto crucial que esse
estudo reforça e que as diretrizes da
American Diabilles Association 2024 já
reconhece. A administração de vitamina D
para pacientes com pré-diabetes
potencialmente beneficia a incidência de
diabetes tipo 2 em populações
específicas. Então, quais populações?
Aquelas com deficiência real
e aquelas com certas características
étnicas. Teve um estudo de 24 que foi
publicado na Curent Opinion Clinical
Nutrition e Metabolic Care, que mostrou
que a eficácia pode variar dependendo de
diferenças étnicas de raça, né, e níveis
sanguíneos de vitamina D no início da
administração.
Outro aspecto que eu preciso destacar
aqui é a relação entre vitamina D e
informação sistêmica.
A vitamina D tem efeitos potentes,
anti-inflamatórios, imunomoduladores e
ela pode regular negativamente a
transcrição de genes de citocinas
pró-inflamatórias, é o caso de teleocina
2 e teleocina 12 e fator de necrose
tumoral alfa.
Então ela vai promover a indução de
linfócitos terreguladores e a produção
de citocinas antiinflamatórias. Por que
que isso importa? Porque a inflamação
crônica de baixo grau está intimamente
ligada ao desenvolvimento de resistência
insulínica e diabé tipo 2.
Uma coisa que me chama a atenção desse
estudo da nutrition e metabolism é que
os triglicerídeos também caíram, tá, com
a vitamina D. Isso faz total sentido
dentro de uma perspectiva metabólica
mais ampla,
porque a vitamina D inibe o sistema
renina jutensina
que prejudica a função das células beta
e o recrutamento do glúteo 4, que é
aquele receptor da insulina, tá? Então
ela também ativa a via de proteína
quinase ativada por MP e previne a
formação de espécies reativas de
oxigênio, aliviando assim a resistência
ulínica. Então, quando melhoramos a
acessibilidade à insulina, mesmo que
sutilmente, todo o perfil lipídico tende
a melhorar. Tem outro ponto que eu quero
que vocês entendam. Existe uma interação
fascinante entre vitamina D e
osteocalcina, que é um marcador de
remodelação óssea. Estudos recentes
mostram que a administração de vitamina
D, melhorando também a resistência
insulínica via aumento dos níveis
céricos de osteocalcina, tá? A
osteocalcina não é osteocalcinha, é
osteocalcina.
por sua vez, estimula as células
betapancreáticas a secretarem má
insulina e melhora a sensibilidade
insulina nos tecidos periféricos. Então
é uma via metabólica que conecta salde
óssa com salde metabólica. Isso não
fazer a menor ideia que tinha essa
conexão entre produção de insulina no
pâncreas e a questão do óscalina dos
ósse
bem. Outra coisa, a vitamina D prepara o
terreno para um bom controle de
insulina.
Mas se eu se dissesse que existe um
composto natural que não só ajuda no
controle glicêmico, mas que mimetiza os
efeitos benéficos da restrição calórica
e do exercício físico e ajuda a perder
peso. Então isso é um fato de otimização
metabólica avançada.
Então, será que você sabia que uma
metaanálise de 2025 publicada no Phitapy
Research que analisou dados de 11
ensaios clínicos anomizados com 614
pacientes diabéticos tipo 2, encontrou
reduções significativas no peso corporal
IMC e circunferência da cintura com
único composto natural. E o mais
intrigante, as doses menores abaixo de
500 mg parece funcionar melhor que as
megadoses. Então vou te explicar em
profundidade o que a ciência mais
recente diz sobre o resveratrol,
transesveratrol
e composição corporal, os mecanismos
moleculares por trás desses efeitos,
quais dosagens realmente funcionam, como
otimizar a absorção desse composto e
porque esse polifenol pode estar sendo
drasticamente subutilizado pela maioria
das pessoas. Então, teve uma fase, não
sei se vocês vão lembrar, por volta de
10 anos atrás, que o Veratrol tava muito
na moda,
o próprio cientista da longevidade, né,
o doutor,
me fugiu o nome dele agora, daqui a
pouco eu lembro, mas enfim, ele tava
muito em voga há 10 anos atrás, depois
ele caiu em desgraça porque teve saiu
uns estudos falando mal do esveratro
falando que ele não funcionava, tá?
Então agora tá sendo feito um resgate do
resveratrol, tá bom? D Sinclair,
lembrei. Então de Sincler,
antes dele promover a nicotinamina
mononiclotídio, ele promovia muito o
resveratrol, tá? E teve uns estudos que
saíram falando mal resveratrol, mas isso
tá sendo revisto.
Então vamos entender o que que o
resveratrol faz a nível celular. Então
esse polifenol encontrado principalmente
na casca da uva roxa, também encontrado
no vinho tinto, como vocês sabem, também
encontrar nas amoras e no amenduim. Ele
age diretamente em duas vias metabólicas
absolutamente cruciais pro metabolismo
energético, a MPK e a Certum.
A MPK que eu já falei dessa live já, a
C1, já falei nessa live também. Então, a
MPK é uma sigla paraa proteína quinás
ativada por AMP. Ela funciona como
sensor de energia das células na bateria
baixa. Lembra que eu falei? Então,
quando os níveis de ATP caem e o MP
sobe, a MPK é ativada e sinaliza para o
corpo entrar em modo de economia e
queima de gordura. Ou seja, economiza
carboidrato e queima gordura. Então
ela inibe a síntese, ou seja, a formação
de ácidos gros de colesterol e
triglicerídeos, enquanto ativa a
oxidação de gorduras, ou seja, a a
queimação das gorduras como fonte de
energia, a queima de gorduras como fonte
de energia e a captação também de
glicose é aumentada. Então, estudos
publicados no journal molecular and
cellular biochemistry demonstram que o
resveratrol ativa potentemente a MPK,
acima como a berberina, assim como
várias outras substâncias, mimetizando
os efeitos da recessão calórica sem você
precisar passar fome.
Já a Certum, que é uma das sertuínas, é
uma desacetilase dependente de nada
mais, ela regula o envelhecimento
celular. a biogênese mitocondrial e o
metabolismo lipídico. Então o
resveratrol ele aumenta, né, os níveis
de cirtium, OK?
O geratrol ele é considerado um dos
maiores ativadores de cirtium, os mais
um dos mais potentes conhecidos. Então,
quando a citeum é ativada, ela
desacetila o PGC1 alfa, que é um cfator,
um coativador transcridicional
que promove a formação de novas
mitocôndrias e aumenta a capacidade
oxidativa das células. Então, mais
mitocôndrias significa mais fornalhas,
queimando gordura.
E aqui fica interessante, tá? Porque a
CRT1 e a MPK não trabalham de forma
isolada. Pesquisas publicadas na CEL
Metabolis mostram que existe uma via
Cirt 1, a MPK Fox 1, onde essas
proteínas se comunicam e potencializam
os efeitos uma da outra. Então, a Fox 1
é um fator de transcrição que quando
ativado aumenta a expressão de genes
envolvidos na lipólise e na resistência
ao estresse oxidativo. Então, o
esveratrol ao ativar essa tríade,
basicamente diz paraas células adiposa,
células de gordura, parem de acumular a
gordura e comecem a liberar pra gente
queimar essa gordura, né? Mas o efeito
resveratrol vai além de simplesmente
mobilizar a gordura. Ele também
interfere na dipogênese, que é a
formação de gordura, o processo de
formação de novas células de gordura.
Então, estudos em cultura de células 3T3
L1, um modelo padrão para estudo de
adipostos, mostram que o esveratrol
reduz significativamente a expressão do
PPE PPAR gama, tá? O PPR gama é um
receptor nuclear que quando ele tá muito
ativo, ele promove a diferenciação de
pré-adipósitos e adipósito maduro e
aumenta o armazenamento de
trigliceridos. Então, ao inibir o PPAR
gama, né, que acontece com resveratrol,
isso vai impedir que células precursoras
se transformem em células de gordura
funcionais.
Simultaneamente, o esveratrol também
reduz a expressão de sp1c,
que é um fator de transcrição
lipogênico, e da fase, que é uma enzima
ácido grasso sintase
responsável pela síntese de novo de
ácido grasso. Então, por outro lado, ele
aumenta a expressão da lipase hormônio
sensível, que é HSL, vai quebrar os
trigliceridos armazenados, liberando
ácidos gros para serem oxidados, ou
seja, vai liberar mais gordura para ser
queimada, tá? Basicamente isso. Um
achado fascinante publicado no Journal
of Pysiology and Biochemistry em4
é que o resveratrol também promove o
chamado browning. Isso é muito
interessante. Ele vai transformar o
tecido adiposo branco do adulto no
tecido adiposo marrom da criança, do
bebezinho, tá? Então, o tecido adiposo
branco é aquele que armazena energia,
enquanto que o tecido adiposo marrom ele
queima energia na forma de calor através
de um processo chamado termogêno. Então,
o bebezinho tem bastante gordura marrom
para proteger ele contra a perda de
calor e vai perdendo esse tecido marrom
conforme a pessoa vai envelhecendo.
Então essa termogênese ocorre graças a
UCP1, que é uma proteína chamada
desacopuladora um, que dissipa o
gradiente de prótons mitocondrial,
gerando calor em vez de ATP. Então,
estudos em modelos animais mostram que o
resveratrol aumenta a expressão de UCP1,
PRD M16 e Cirt 3 no tecido gorduroso,
essencialmente transformando gordura
preguiçosa em gordura metabolicamente
ativa. Muito interessante isso, né?
Um estudo de 2024 foi publicado no
Molecular and Cellular Endocrinology
avaliou camundongos que foram submetidos
à cirurgia de tirar útero ou
fereectomia, né, para modelo de
menopausa. E encontrou que a
suplementação com resveratrol reduziu o
peso corporal e a diposidade visceral,
além de melhorar os níveis de glicose,
colesterol total e triglicerítes. O
mecanismo envolveu
aumento na expressão de genes
temogênicos no tecido adiposo marrom.
Agora vamos aos números clínicos que
realmente importam. A metaanálise la RUT
e colaboradores que foi publicado em
outubro de 25 no Phytotherapy Research,
que é mais atualizado sobre esse tema do
Resveratrol. Então, nesse caso, os
pesquisadores fizeram buscas abrangentes
no Web of Science, no Pubmed, no Scopus
e no CCRIN. até fevereiro de 2023
incluíram também apenas ensaios clínicos
randomizados, só estudos mais eh
importantes, né, mais bem feitos
e também os estudos controlados por
placebo em adultos com diabetes tipo 2.
Então, os resultados mostraram que 614
participantes tiveram redução média de
0,44 kg no peso corporal com intervalo
de confiança de 95%
entre - 0,8 e 0. valor de confiança do P
de 0,048
tiveram redução de 0,19 pontos do MC e
redução de 0,8 cm de circunferência da
cintura.
Então não houve efeitos significativos
na circunferência do quadril ou na
relação cintura quadril. Então se você
foi ver, foi uma perda pequena da
circunferência, do peso, do MC, né?
Porém, já foi uma coisa interessante
para ajudar num processo de
emagrecimento.
Então, resveratrol realmente vale a pena
ser tomado para ajudar no processo de
emagrecimento. Sozinho fazer pouca
coisa, mas vai ajudar.
Então você pode estar se perguntando,
menos de 15 kg de peso perdido e menos
de 1 cm de cintura, isso parece bem
pouco, mas
pensa bem que isso vai ser mais uma
estratégia e não vai ser uma coisa
isolada, tá? Existe uma diferença
importante entre significância
estatística e significância clínica. Uma
perda de peso menor de que 1 kg,
provavelmente não vai por si só melhorar
nenhum desfecho de saúde de forma
mensurável. Porém, existe nuances
críticas que precisam ser consideradas.
Primeiro, a duração dos estudos
incluídos variou apenas 4 a 24 semanas,
segundo as doses utilizadas foram muito
heterogêneas, variando de 100 mg
de resveratrol por dia. Então essa
variabilidade enorme introduz o que
chamamos de alta heterogeneidade
estatística.
Isso dificulta tirar conclusões
definitivas.
E terceiro aqui, talvez o ponto mais
importante, metanálises anteriores
identificaram padrão dose resposta não
linear. Então, a metaanálise de 2019
publicada no Obesity Reviews,
que analisou 36 ensaios com foco em
obesidade, encontrou que doses menores,
especificamente
abaixo de 500 mg de zeratrol, são mais
eficazes que megadoses. E a duração do
tratamento precisa de pelo menos 12
semanas, no mínimo 12 semanas paraa
gente poder obter resultados
consistentes. Além disso, os efeitos
foram mais pronunciados em pessoas com
obesidade e diabetes tipo 2 comparado a
populações saudáveis. Outro ponto
importante é que os benefícios do
resveratrol muito além da balança. Teve
uma metaanálise 2024 publicada no
Frontiers docinology que avaliou os
efeitos da inflamação e estresse
liquidativo em diabético tipo 2 e o
resveratrol reduziu significativamente
marcadores inflamatórios como TNF alfa e
proteína ser reativa. Isso é relevante
porque a inflamação crônica de baixo
grau, característica da obesidade do
diabetes, trava o metabolismo e favorece
o acúmulo de gordura visceral. Então, ao
reduzir essa inflamação, o resveratol
cria um ambiente metabólico mais
favorável à pesa de gordura. E quanto
aos efeitos na sensibilidade insulínica,
uma revisão sistemática publicada no
Nutrition and Metabolism, que incluiu
nove ensaios com 283 participantes,
mostrou que o esveratrol melhorou
significativamente a glicemia de jejum
0,29
m/ por L e os níveis de insulina em 0,64
unidades por mililro. Então, o mecanismo
envolve aumento da expressão do receptor
grute 4 e também aumento da translocação
do receptor.
Então ele é um transportador de glicó
dependente insulina esse glute 4, tá?
Então ele vai ajudar a pegar a glicose
da membrana celular para dentro da
célula.
Estudos em modelos animais, diabetes
publicados no diabetes journal mostram
que o esveratrol aumenta o conteúdo de
glúteo 4 no músculo esquelético e reduz
o glúteo do fígado. Glúteo dois no
fígado, normalizando os fluxos de
glicose nesses tecidos. Pessoal, eu vou
encerrar por agora porque eu tô bem ruim
de voz aqui
e não tem ninguém acompanhando ao vivo,
tá? Dona Paula, eu acho que ela foi
paraa outra live
e não tem ninguém se manifestando aqui,
tá bom?
Então, eh, tinha mais alguns assuntos
para falar hoje, mas eu vou deixar para
a semana que vem. Semana que vem, não,
para daqui a duas semanas, tá? Pra
próxima live aí do nível dois.
E eu agradeço muitíssimo aí quem
participou dessa live, vai ficar gravada
e depois eu vou deixar também o índice
dessa desse vídeo e o resumo no
documento para vocês acompanharem. Um
abraço, um beijo no coração de vocês.